- I'm in New York City,
beautiful New York City!
And today I'm letting Twitter run my day.
But first things first,
I have to get a bagel.
Come on, post office,
don't do that.
(upbeat electronic music)
New York City, the Big Apple.
And you know, I've actually
been to New York a few times,
but I don't do a lot of exploring.
I've always been here for work.
So I'm having Twitter
make all my decisions
and, hopefully, I'll
learn more about New York.
First things first, though,
where should I get bagels?
So I asked Twitter where
I should get bagels.
They said Tompkins Bagels.
So I'm gonna put out
four options for bagels,
I'm gonna let Twitter decide.
I'll let 'em choose between plain,
garlic, pumpernipple,
(laughs)
pumpernipple,
pumpernickel, and chocolate chip.
Tompkins Bagels!
(ding)
Got my bagel,
although it wasn't a chocolate chip bagel,
they were out of that,
so I got a garlic bagel
and I got scallion and bacon spread.
I'm keepin' it real.
Keepin' it real real.
♫ Pigeons eating pizza
♫ Pigeons eating pizza ♫
I saw some pigeons eating
pizza this morning.
- (beep) yeah, man.
Welcome to New York.
- They love a good slice.
Bagel.
Oh, very garlicky.
After you get past that
first initial shock,
this is actually very, very good.
Also it's humid and hot in New York.
I need some new clothes.
Okay, so I got my crew with me.
Are we gonna go out in New York
and see where we go next, great.
Yes, elevator from the future!
- [Voiceover] Seventh floor lobby.
- So I asked yesterday
for a bunch of people
to just send me a bunch of
things to do in New York,
I tweeted it out.
Lots of tweets came back.
Oh, (beep) there's a
farmers market going on!
Those are things.
Let's do the polling for five minutes.
It was very close between
flowers, fruit, and bread.
You want to get some raspberries?
- [Voiceover] We have to go to class.
- [Blurred Woman] We have to go to class.
- Oh, well, I'm getting raspberries.
You can get raspberries with me.
Great.
She's, (stammering)
you're from Egypt?
- [Voiceover] Yeah!
- Yo, I met you on!
- [Voiceover] Hi!
- [Keith] She tweeted at me earlier.
She's vacationing from Egypt.
- I am.
We don't have raspberries in Egypt,
we only have the frozen ones.
- [Keith] Oh, really?
Have you had fresh raspberries?
- [Woman] No.
- [Keith] You've never
had fresh raspberries?
- [Woman] I've never
had fresh raspberries,
only the frozen ones.
- [Keith] Are you kidding?
Oh my gosh, this is,
oh my goodness.
- [Woman] Are these raspberries?
- Raspberries.
- [Woman] They're raspberries.
- [Keith] Bam.
We also bought some edible flowers
because those seem fun.
First, so we're gonna try raspberries
then edible flowers.
But let's just do this.
Grab a raspberry.
So as you can hear, at
this point in the video,
we don't have good sound.
I don't know what happened.
I'm editing it right now.
Anyhow, she tries a raspberry.
She loves them, obviously, they're great.
I love them too.
She talks about how they remind
her of her dad and a tree.
- It's a very cute story
that I unfortunately
don't have the sound for.
And then we stuff a bunch
of flowers in our mouths
and I gag on them.
(gagging)
Alright, moving on.
And so now we're gonna go buy clothes.
We're going to a place
called Scotch and Stone?
- [Voiceover] Scotch and Soda.
- Close enough!
Scotch and Soda.
I'm taking off my clothes.
Okay, so I'm in the changing room
and I tried on two outfits.
So I'm gonna tweet out pictures of those,
see what people vote on,
see which outfit they want me to buy.
I also have to make sure
that they have these shirts in large
'cause i tried on mediums
and I ain't a medium here,
know what I'm saying?
(pop music)
So I just got my outfit.
I look so fine.
I only showed you my crotch.
And now we're gonna pick out food,
so we asked the internet
if we should get pizza,
street meat, or a hot sub sandwich.
We're gonna let them vote for five minutes
and then we're gonna go eat.
That's how it go.
♫ She 'on't freak with it
♫ On fleek with it
♫ If she bad, I'ma smash
♫ She a freak with it ♫
- We're going down the train
to get to a pizza place.
Huge smiles all around the whole train.
- Oh, yeah, nobody's smiling, huh?
Must have been an illusion.
This place is darling.
What are we in?
- Wow.
He's got a nice place.
Look at all those bongs!
(leisurely music)
(ding)
Okay, can we get four slices of cheese?
Look at that pizza.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, it's all on top of itself.
So we just finished having pizza,
I had two slices of cheese,
and now we're actually taking a break
from the Twitter adventure.
I gotta go to Central Park
and sit with a cup of money
so somebody on Facebook Live can win $200.
Pretty good.
Welcome, everybody, again to Cup of Money!
I tried to be on a boat.
There wasn't enough internet on the boat.
Not enough internet on the boat,
so I just decided I would come up here.
And this is I'm stationed
with my water bottle of money.
What do you gotta say?
What do you say?
- I have to get back to work!
- [Keith] What do you say?
You say a thing.
- Gimme the money?
- [Keith] No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no!
- Gimme dat coffee, boy!
- [Keith] There it is!
There it is!
You've done it, Eleanor!
You've done it!
Here are your $200.
- Oh my god.
- We'll see you next time on Cup of Money!
So we're leaving Central Park.
We had a good time with Cup of Money.
It took a little bit longer than expected,
so I'm going back to Union Stair.
So I'm going back to, for (beep).
I'm just tired, I'm just tired, you know?
I'm just tired.
I'm having a hard time.
Pretty New York City, pretty building.
Pretty this.
Pretty, oh, police car.
Alright, we're back in Union Square.
I'm gonna go get a hot dog
per someone's suggestion
and then someone else suggested
I ask people about sausage.
Those seem to work hand in hand.
Let's do it.
Can I get one hot dog?
- [Voiceover] Ketchup, mustard?
- [Keith] Just mustard, please.
How do you like these sausages, good?
- [Voiceover] Good.
- [Keith] Agreed.
(pop music)
Back in the space elevator.
I meant to turn the camera on myself,
but I'm just filming the door.
How was your day?
(group cheering)
- We're back!
- The final question is
am I gonna go see Book of
Mormon with Eugene and Ned
or should I go see Hamilton with Zach?
You guys gotta vote.
Okay, bye.
(drum roll)
Winner is--
- Not Zach!
- Actually, yeah, you know,
Hamilton won, but I can't afford that,
so we're at Book of Mormon.
Sorry, guys, we're at Book of Mormon.
See you later.
(pop music)
- [Voiceover] Suck it, Keith.
- Suck it, Keith.
- [Voiceover] Suck it.